[Musique]
certains d'entre vous ne reviendront pas
ce n'est pas une autre façon de vous dire que
ces statistiques de base nous disent que si
dans vos derniers instants vous voyez la mort oh
merci pas si la mort pense aux
vivants et sachez ceci que votre sacrifice
sera  n'ont pas été en vain cela ne fait
aucune différence qui gagne la guerre est
quelqu'un qui est mort vous dites que ces
balles à tête ont explosé approximativement monsieur
je veux voir boum ne tuez pas les bateaux
vous pensez toujours que vous allez avoir
qu'est-ce que c'est que cette
folie absurde est contagieuse d'accord d'accord alors
super oui monsieur
[Applaudissements]